MALE SPEAKER 1: Hi.
GDG is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like to ask
questions--
VIC FRYZEL: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Vic Fryzel, and this
is Steve Bazyl.
We're here today to talk about
the Google Drive SD.
And specifically today, we're
going to be doing an app
review of one of the Drive SDK
applications that integrates
via the drive API.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, and today
we're going to take a look at
an application called Loupe,
which does image collages.
It let's you pick in photos from
all different sources,
from everything from the
Facebook to Google Image
Search to Drive and Instagram,
and so on.
And they did some drive
integration a while back, and
we're going to go through some
of the really cool things they
did and highlight some of the
areas where maybe they could
work on tightening up
the integration.
VIC FRYZEL: Exactly.
So we're going to start off by
watching the application from
the Chrome Web Store.
So Steve has the application
open here.
And let's start off by
going through their
Chrome Web Store listing.
They did a pretty
good job so far.
They have very excellent
photos and an excellent
description of their
application.
This is really important to
make sure that users are
attracted to the application.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
These are really engaging
photos that show how the
application works, what you can
do, what the output is.
And if you go through, we're
not going to go through all
this, but they did a really nice
job at highlighting what
all of the features of the app
are and why it would be cool
to play with.
VIC FRYZEL: So Steve
already has
this application installed.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
I'm going to go over to my drive
here, actually, and I
have just a bunch
of photos here.
This is just my wife and I on
vacation in Thailand here.
So nothing too exciting,
but you can go in and
create a new collage.
So one of the cool things
they did is they do
single sign-on correctly.
It already knows who I
am and everything.
And they have a really easy
getting started process in
terms of connecting to
different accounts.
You can see here, it's already
logged in from Drive.
Actually, it already
has my photos.
And if I want I can go and
connect to Facebook, or even
pull photos from say public
Twitter feeds and so on.
So it's a pretty cool app
the way this all works.
But today, were obviously mostly
interested in Drive.
So let's just bring in--
actually, let's not
do these two here.
And we'll add the photos.
So actually it looks pretty
quick in terms of the
responsiveness of bringing
in the photos from Drive.
Then you can actually
see some of the--
just play around with it.
Let's do-- since this is cloud
storage, let's make our photos
into a little cloud
shape here.
Actually, these photos here,
these little South Park
characters are ones we
do of my wife and I
for our annual picnics.
We'll just parse all
together over here.
So that's--
VIC FRYZEL: This is the primary
use case, pulling in a
bunch of photos from one
of these services and
then making a collage.
So you can drag the photos
around and edit the collage.
You can zoom in, zoom out.
STEVE BAZYL: And they have a
public gallery where people
can share the collages, or you
can share them through
services like Drive.
So just for testing purposes
here, we're going to just go
and save this, and we can
just give this a name.
I'll just say Test for now
and make it just private.
So this is where one of the
improvements that I was--
and to be fair to them, a lot
of the feedback that we're
going to go through today, we've
already provided to the
developers at Loupe.
And hopefully, they'll
have an updated
version out pretty soon.
But this is a case where
the behavior wasn't
really what I expected.
If I go back into my Drive--
VIC FRYZEL: Oh, we
lost connection.
STEVE BAZYL: Yes, we did.
Oh, here we go.
So when we go back to Drive,
I don't have that picture.
I clicked Save, but
where is it?
It's not in my drive.
And turns out that in order to
do this, you actually have to
do a second save to put
this back in to Drive.
So now I can say Save to Drive,
and it will save it.
VIC FRYZEL: And when we come
back to Drive, it's actually
saved under an unusual name.
STEVE BAZYL: Correct.
VIC FRYZEL: Which is Loupe and
then a bunch of characters.
STEVE BAZYL: Right.
And as a user, I would've
expected that to basically
pick up the name that I just
put in earlier here.
So a couple of little things
like that, from a user's
perspective, they do appear
to be unpolished.
VIC FRYZEL: So up until this
point, Loupe has done a couple
of things very well.
I mean, their UI is obviously
very slick.
And even in the integrations
with Drive that they already
have, they're well integrated
via these buttons and
dialogues and everything, and
everything just works.
So that's very good.
We would like to see a couple
of tweaks, though, to this
integration.
STEVE BAZYL: Right.
VIC FRYZEL: So one of the
tweaks, for instance, that
Loupe could have made was
to use our own picker.
And we provide a picker, which
is essentially a dialogue
allowing you to select
files from Drive.
In this case, though, it's
probably a good thing that
Loupe didn't do that.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
This is a conversation that
I've had with the
developers at Loupe.
The trade-offs and using our
picker versus theirs.
And because they pull in photos
from so many different
sources-- they have Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram, Tumbler,
Google Image Search,
actually--
they wanted this to come
across as a unified
experience.
Whereas if they used the picker
from each of these
different services,
it would've been a
little jarring to users.
In this case, they end up asking
for a lot of access to
Drive, but the user experience
is actually really good here.
VIC FRYZEL: And actually, when
you select the Drive tab, you
can see that Loupe has gone
through a lot of work to make
sure that this is very fast
and user-friendly.
This could be implemented less
efficiently, and if it had
been, users would see
loading signs here
and things like that.
So they did a really good
job of a custom picker.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, they did a
good job optimizing this.
And a lot of this is made
possible by the fact that we
provide thumbnail links for
these images, so that they're
just downloading lower res
versions until they actually
need it for building
the collage.
VIC FRYZEL: So another thing
that Loupe could have done
slightly differently was instead
originating from
getloupe.com, users might find
it more sensible sometimes to
start from within Drive.
STEVE BAZYL: Right, so let's
say I go back to my photos
folder here, and I just want
to create a collage with a
couple of these pictures.
It would be nice if I could
do Open With Loupe and
then bring these in.
We actually have some
multi-select.
I can select all of these and
import these in, but it's just
not an option here.
And it would be a pretty easy
thing for them to add.
VIC FRYZEL: And not only that,
you would get a lot of other
nice features of the Drive user
interface like Search,
for instance.
You could search for only
wedding photos.
STEVE BAZYL: Correct.
VIC FRYZEL: And just make a
collage of just selecting all
of the wedding photos.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
So a very, very cool thing they
could do and pretty easy.
The other thing, as I mentioned
earlier, we did talk
to the developers there
and gave them
a lot of this feedback.
One thing that Loupe actually
used as a demo for back at IO
was the sharing dialogue.
So just like we can
go in and--
oops, wrong share.
I can share here.
We actually have this
dialogue as now
an embeddable component.
And we actually got to work with
them in demoing this at
IO, and they had integrated it
into their development version
of Loupe so that when I did go
in here and create a collage
and Save to Drive, it would
automatically display that
sharing dialogue so that I
can share that with my
friends and my family.
So that's something that I know
that they've worked on.
It is in their sandbox, and I do
hope that hopefully pretty
soon that will be available
to all users.
VIC FRYZEL: So that's also a
really good idea for them
because if Loupe in the future
decides to store a native
collage format in Google Drive
so that when you save a
collage you can reopen it in
Loupe, sharing the collage to
other users who don't
necessarily have Loupe
installed will drive
installations to their
application.
Because we will know Loupe's
native client format requires
the application.
And once that happens, we can
suggest to users by this
mechanism that they should
go and install Loupe.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, exactly.
It might be a little hard to
see, but there is this Chrome
Web Store icon down at the
bottom, which will then let me
go find some apps that
work with this.
So PicMonkey, Marqueed, Hello
Fax, and it looks like we have
a new one, Cloud Paint, which
I have not seen before.
So, as you said, sharing this
and also, you're right.
I don't know if I have a demo of
that readily available, but
with the custom formats, you do
get an even more prominent
display of an upsell of--
VIC FRYZEL: The application's
icon shows up very prominently
on the bottom.
A user is just one click away
from its Chrome Web Store
listing installing
the application.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
So a really, really good
way to get additional
users to the app.
VIC FRYZEL: So in saving to
Google Drive, Loupe would have
to detect that a user originated
from Google Drive.
And then throughout their user
interface here, they'd have to
propagate that.
And once a user finally clicks
Save, the user probably wants
to save the collage back to
Drive, because that's where
they started from.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
VIC FRYZEL: So that's something
that would be a
little bit different when
choosing to save a collage
here instead of just saving
natively within Loupe.
STEVE BAZYL: We could even do
recursive collages here.
But yeah, that's definitely a
bit of feedback that they are
aware of, and again, hopefully
will be in the next version
once that's available.
VIC FRYZEL: And Loupe doesn't
even have to go so far as to
use our common sharing
dialogue.
They could use the Drive API
once they've created a Loupe
collage natively in Drive to
share that with other users.
So we have built-in access
control lists for each file.
And Loupe could just use that
to send out an email
notification or share
the file.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
And each of these networks for
sharing has a slightly
different way of doing it.
And the nice thing is we give
developers the choice of
really low-level, API-level
sharing, or just a nice
pre-built widget.
VIC FRYZEL: So, what do
you think, Steve?
STEVE BAZYL: Overall?
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
STEVE BAZYL:I'd give it a solid
B. I mean, it's a really
fun app to play with.
When they first went into the
Chrome Web Store and showed
off their Drive integration, I
had a lot of fun playing with,
creating collages, and so on.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, same.
STEVE BAZYL: But there are some
of those a little tiny
missing features that aren't
that hard to implement, but I
think go a really far way
just to make it a really
all-around solid app.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
I definitely agree, a B. The
one feature that I would at
least like to see is just saving
back to Google Drive.
Even if the user doesn't
originate in Google Drive, the
ability to just automatically
save in Google Drive with a
proper title and proper,
maybe, metadata, like
indexable text and things like
that, so that the collages are
searchable.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, and that would be
something they could do pretty
easily in terms of using the
source image names as the
indexable text.
So they could find collages
that include a particular
image, which is actually kind
of a pretty cool use of the
search features.
VIC FRYZEL: So, everyone, that
is Loupe, the collage
application in the Chrome Web
Store for Google Drive.
Anything else you'd
like to add?
STEVE BAZYL: No.
I'd just encourage people to try
it out or try out any app
in the Chrome Web Store.
There are some that are really,
really solid, some
that need a bit of work.
But each one is an opportunity
to learn and figure out what
works and what doesn't.
VIC FRYZEL: So, Steve, if
a user's interested in
installing this, how
do they do it from
the Chrome Web Store?
STEVE BAZYL: Pretty easy.
You can go to the Chrome Web
Store, and we do have a Google
Drive collection where you
can go and find all the
applications.
VIC FRYZEL: So Loupe is right
there on the bottom right?
STEVE BAZYL: Yep.
This order actually
does change.
It's a little bit dynamic, but
you can go, and in this case,
I already have it installed.
But you can just click
on that, or
Save or Add to Chrome.
The one thing is you don't
actually need Google Chrome to
install a Drive app.
It will work with any browser.
It's just, right now,
this is where we're
surfacing the apps.
So go try them out.
There's a bunch of others
here that I'd love
to do reviews on.
VIC FRYZEL: If you have
any requests for
reviews, please tell us.
STEVE BAZYL: Or if you have an
app yourself and you would
like our feedback on it, we'd
be happy to spend some time
playing with it and getting
into some suggestions.
VIC FRYZEL: Great.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
VIC FRYZEL: So that about
wraps it up for us.
Please tune in later this week,
We're going to have
another Google Developers
Live session on the
Google Drive SDK.
STEVE BAZYL: And do we have
a topic for that one?
Is that going to be--
VIC FRYZEL: I don't think
we have a topic yet.
STEVE BAZYL: OK.
Well, we'll figure
it out and--
VIC FRYZEL: We kind of
live on the edge.
STEVE BAZYL: That's right.
So that's it for us,
and I hope to see
guys again on Thursday.
VIC FRYZEL: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]